There is a way out that there is a way to do more,
to get more,
to obtain more.
But I personally don't want to lose all that I've been able to get.
So I need to make sure that I do everything to keep it
so I can't be content.
MMM.
So there is an understanding,
but I refuse to click on the switch of hi.
So even if you like,
even if you have more money than you'll ever spend for the rest of your life,
that's not what it's about.
No.
It's about the inspiring people and the influence and constantly giving back and
moving forward in a positive way.
And the only way you can do that as a stack,
it's the story,
man.
Yeah.
You know where,
where we're all writing a book.
What's your book look like?
What is your fucking book look like?
Like your life is a book.
You got a bunch of chapters in your book,
but when they closed that book,
how good was the book?
How good was your book?
What was the ending to your book?
If the ending to my book can be so amazing because of all that was done at the
money.
All that was accomplish the first to do the man that did this.
He calls the merger between this,
because of his commitment and growth to this,
the communities were then given this made education,
this change the way to schooling was blah,
blah,
blah.
Gave books,
go computers,
gave them all of the things that can be associated with you and your existence
become a part of the chapters in your book.
So my drive is about my book.
I was a New York Times number one best seller.
People will be done.
They did it right in another book.
Yeah.
What's it happen?
What happens if you are two time New York Times number one bestseller?
If you get the two,
what happens if you get the three?
Hey man,
how books become successful?
Who publishes them?
I want to start a publishing company.
Hartbeat publishing.
Why not?
That's the thing.
All I'm doing is sparking though awareness and others to go,
why not?
Why can't I create?
Why can't I start?
Why can't I be a business?
Why can't I be a CEO?
Why can't I be a tech guru?
Why can I fucking create cooking privates lotion?
Since there's so much that some people just don't understand they can do.
Let me be a spark to show how much,
how many different that you don't have to do.
Just one thing.
When it's all said and done,
my book is going to be full of all the shit that Kevin Hart did cause I never
was content with doing just one,
two or three.
Why not,
Kevin?
Why are you creating fucking health and wellness products?
Why not?
I'm big on health and wellness.
Why can't I?
Why can't I try to create something that I feel is fucking great and jump into a
space and I'm already in already give 100% of me in this space?
Why not?
Why can't I talk about financial wealth?
Why can't I go back and educate those that don't know why not?
You don't have time.
I'll make time would you certainly can,
but it's just so unusual.
Someone dedicates that much energy and time to to giving back and getting
involved with the kind of projects that you're talking about as well as be super
ambitious with your own career.
It makes me happy.
No,
I can tell I'm,
I'm genuinely happy.
Discovery makes me happy.
Like when you find different things to be excited about,
it makes me happy and it's weird when it clicks and school days to tell you all
the time,
information is key.
Read these books.
There's so much Knology man,
fuck that book.
Got Tired of read that book.
I want to go home.
God Damn Sonic the hedgehog that want to play.
I'm at level three.
I ain't got time to read his book.
The information and stuff that was forced down your throat at a certain age,
you just,
you just may not be receiving it correctly,
but then it clicks.
You may gain information differently and what you do with that information is up
to you.
But people,
people have different roles.
They can go down.
The education wasn't my pick of choice.
It,
it didn't do it for me,
but the knowledge and the common sense that I have naturally allow me to gain
information,
apply it differently.
It allowed me to grow smart in so many different avenues to where I said,
oh my God,
I found my niche,
I found my talent,
and now there's other things that my talent can take me to.
I don't have the all the knowledge and awareness,
but I can allow myself with people to do that,
can teach me because now guess what?
Learning is cool.
Yeah.
That's what happens when you don't have to do it anymore,
right?
It's all in your kid.
They force you into this school.
Don't want to learn,
but then when you get out and you realize like,
oh,
this actually benefits may,
this is making me a better person.
It makes me wiser.
It's 100% the reality and it's weird how it happens,
but when you go,
oh my God,
learning and knowledge is power.
Fuck.
They used to tell me this when I was 10 yes,
10 11 years old.
I heard that shit all the time.
Now I finally get it.
Damn.
I'm about to be 40 to y'all.
It's time to get the gut their code,
but I got it.
Yeah,
it hits you at a different time and when it does,
big side about it,
man.
Excited.
I'm excited about with 50 years,
I'm just now getting a 40.
Do you read books?
I don't read a lot of books.
Do you listen to books on tape?
I have listened to books and all that.
Let's do what Tony Robbins.
He's great.
Tony's uh,
uh,
like
I like his approach to giving information.
Um,
I like his attitude in general.
I like podcasts.
I like things that are real and out of presented in front of me.
I like information that I can go to the source in and touch and talk to the
mayor if I'm reading a book.
It's a book that was recommended by such and such and the person who gave it to
me.
And after reading that book,
I learned more about the individual that I thought I already knew and now I
gained more.
Michelle Obama's book.
Great Book.
Great fucking book.
I met her,
talked to her.
I've been in the same rooms.
I've seen her success.
What did her book going to be about?
Mm,
overeat.
A book.
Wow.
I get it.
I get why it's moving.
All the units that is moving.
I get why women are reading his book and walking away feeling better,
feeling like they can't.
I get it.
Oh Wow.
Hmm.
Certain friends,
Dwayne Wade wrote a book that's focused on being a father,
his road to becoming a better father.
What he went through with his kid's mother.
How you developed a relationship than a bond with his son's like nobody else.
Wow.
Didn't know that day.
That's dope.
I love how you put it on page.
There's certain things that you just want to know.
Uh,
certain books help.
I understand why people read books.
I get what the information does.
You know,
the book that I'm working on now is all about the mental approach that you have
with life and people not understanding that your biggest enemy is you.
My whole book is about you battling yourself.
People don't understand is you against you.
The only person that gets in your way as you,
nobody else is.
You know,
when you write a book like this,
and especially about something like this,
this is the way you've managed to navigate through life art.
Do you,
do you write it out in essays?
do you,
do you have like bullet points that you think about?
And then once you have those bullet points in your head and then you write on
those out,
how do you do it?
I'll show you leave it on your phone.
It's all,
all voice notes and transcripts.
Okay?
So because of your time,
you don't have,
you don't have the time to sit and actually write.
So you need somebody that you can talk to for hours,
hours,
hours on it.
Hey,
I need an hour block,
an hour for me.
I got some stuff we want to talk to you about.
Kev,
what was that?
All right.
Book title,
idea,
subtitle,
ideas.
My dedication is my introductions.
Um,
within my introductions,
these all powerful paragraphs and things that I've just said that are now
transcript.
I get to go back and read it.
Um,
let me see here.
There's no conversation at all.
Every one of them.
Um,
no conversation at all.
And that's what the Internet has allowed people to do.
The Internet has allowed people to skip steps one through 30 has a lot of people
to jump straight to 100.
Fuck you got a job off,
take them down.
You should be dead.
Oh God.
Fucking can't stand this.
Whatever.
The hate of the anger is when listen,
one,
listen.
Okay.
When I listen and I can change,
I'm not that guy.
We're doing these weird things now that people aren't taking the time to sit and
think through.
What I've understood is that what people are doing has nothing to do with me.
I should always be a step ahead because I'm thinking differently because I'm
thinking about myself.
Making myself better puts me in a position to make others better.
Be the example,
not the problem.
The best way to take away the problem is to alienate yourself from,
these are visitors thoughts.
It's fucking thoughts.
I can go through and just read it.
This is so you just have these philosophies,
the way you live your life and you just just speak it.
Just speak it Diane.
So now this is all true landscape.
Look along with this.
That's incredible.
This all fucking transcript.
This is all.
So I'll just go back throughout the day and I read it and I say,
this is great.
This makes sense.
This didn't let me reword this.
I make sure that it's all flowing together.
And at the end of the day,
what's my reason for the book?
My reason for the book is to make people better.
My reason for the book is to make people understand.
Yeah,
we all agree.
We all should think that we're great.
There's no reason for you to not think that you're great.
If you don't think you're great,
ask yourself why?
Why don't you think the highest of yourself when you do?
People have no,
you have no choice but to follow suit.
Mm got no choice but to follow suit.
A lot of people,
their base it on their past,
they base it on the life that they've experienced up until this moment makes you
better.
Yeah,
it does make it back.
She better makes you smarter.
Yeah.
I'd like to hear I like you said.
Yeah,
man.
That's what's interesting about it.
That's what's interesting about life.
You can hear a guy like you say that and then it changes your perspective and
then you'll go out and take action that you might not have taken before.
I had a five 85 on my sat confessions.
I didn't even take my confession.
You 400 for putting your name on a paper.
It's true story.
Wow.
I guess a,
I did Abracadabra all way.
True Story.
I swear to God,
I handle my mother's grave,
a,
B,
c,
a,
d all the way down.
I didn't care because it was a class trip.
That same day I wanted to go.
Great adventure.
I was told that not taking my sats seriously,
but prohibit me from furthering myself in life.
I thought I was told at the moment,
I said,
damn,
maybe I should've.
Maybe I shouldn't apply myself.
Maybe I shouldn't be different.
When I saw all my friends get their test scores back and they were static,
800 909 sixties everybody's going to college.
It felt like the biggest idiot in the fucking world,
the biggest idiot in the fucking world because the same people that I want to
rush to go to great adventure with.
They'd taken an sat the week before.
They already got their work done.
They did everything they were supposed to do.
So that moment of fun was real fun for them.
I was the only dumb ass that didn't prioritize and take care of my shit.
So I'm the only one going to community college.
Everybody's else off the Villanova Temple University,
Drexel University.
God Damn,
I just got left behind.
Why didn't y'all tell me that y'all did it the week before?
How can I tell me that we was serious about the college shit?
Y'All ain't telling me y'all was trying to go to temple or Drexel.
All weight
is because my life isn't their life.
Their,
they're focused on themselves.
Wow.
They're,
they're doing what they're supposed to do.
Hey Jack Ass.
Go sit by yourself and figure it out because this is where you should be less
than learn.
Any opportunity given should be taking series from this point on because if not,
you can find yourself feeling just like this.
It's hard to get down on myself and fucking moment and learn from it.
Learn from it.
Now if I got to take a goddamn tests,
you best believe I'm studying for that fuck test cause I don't want to feeling
like I'm the guy that didn't prepare.
Now I've got a story to tell my kids about what it feels like to be the kid in
class that didn't prepare.
This got the words gray,
when to give all those grades back,
but it's because of my experience.
I don't look down on those moments.
You take those moments,
you make the best of them because they're live lessons.
That sample you're saying is positive,
but it's really just simplicity.
That's real drill.
It's real and it's your life experience and it's your life's lessons.
One a hundred percent but the fact that a guy like you comes out and talks about
it like that,
that's where it makes it really powerful cause it's not just something that you
learned from,
but now other people can learn from your past too.
That's what I'm hoping they'll look at themselves and they did realize like we
all start from a different spot.
You're not saying,
yeah,
this is why I'm so candidate.
I'm so candidate.
I'm so open.
They're there.
There is no like guys,
I'm,
I'm fine with being an open book.
I'm fine with the good,
the bad,
the ugly.
I'm fine being flawed.
I'm fine with all the things that have happened to me that have been exposed.
I'm fine with it all.
I don't hide from it.
I don't run from it.
I don't,
uh,
avoid any of it.
I'm fine.
It's all right.
It's a bed that I made for myself.
I happily lay in it and I'll be fine figuring it out.
Moving forward,
son,
don't stop for nobody,
man.
Sundo fuck.
Stop.
Sign going to be up in the morning regardless.
That sun is going to be up in the morning regard,
regardless of how I fucking feel and how depressed I am.
The Sun is going to fucking shine in the morning and at nighttime to moon going
to be there and you're gonna look up these days going to keep going by.
So do you let the days go by and look up and you didn't waste a year doing what?
What do you just pick it up?
All right,
well I got to figure it out.
Made some mistakes as life goes on.
Let me figure out life from this point.
I'm a life goes on type of guy.
You're a bad mother fucker.
Kevin Hart,
very,
very inspirational and I'm,
I'm really glad you came down here and talked about it.
I'm more than glad.
I think that is that
it took too long actually.
And this is the first of a,
of what will be many man.
I'm for sure.
I'm a fan too.
I just think what you're doing is not just inspirational in terms of like what
you've been able to achieve and who you are,
but also inspirational and how you're so dedicated to helping other people.
That means a lot to me.
It's very,
it's very motivating.
It's very powerful.
I wanna I want all your listeners know that is not,
um,
it's not the top.
No,
this is,
this is no way it could be you if you were doing that just for talk and be like,
listen,
just fake it and then become that guy because you're,
you're on.
It's something,
if you could do that and just say it in dark,
fucking forget about whatever it's fake or not.